Okay. So I'm going to continue what Courtney was talking about. I have some similar slides
and hopefully we'll tell you something new. We all know about Menin now. It's important for
leukemia development, KMT2A and MPM1. So it is a tumor suppressor in the endocrine glands. Maybe
I glanced over it in previous talks. So mutations in Men1 cause the multiple endocrine neoplasia
syndrome because this is a scaffold protein that affects transcription. So it is something that's
going to be context and tissue dependent. So bear that in mind to think about the role of Menin,
not just as impairing leukemogenesis, but could affect other genes that are important
in transcription. So the main targets that are being investigated with Menin inhibitors are
KMT2A rearranged leukemias, MPM1 mutant acute leukemias,
and now we know NUP98 rearranged leukemias. And the mechanism is by disruption of binding of
Menin to KMT2A that down-regulates Hox expression, has an anti-leukemic effect.
So essentially maintenance is targeting MRD, even the MRD that we cannot measure.
And in this case, we are trying to do through the Breakthrough Cancer Foundation. This is an effort
between MD Anderson, MSK, Hopkins, MIT, and the Farber is to,
not just target MRD, we have trials to target MRD, but we're trying to develop better methods to
test MRD, including what Dr. Elizade was referring to. Part of this trial is something done by Lukas
at Hopkins, where he's doing whole genome sequencing to find specific markers of MRD
and allow us to measure MRD better. But we're also trying to collect samples so we understand why
those cells persist, what makes them unique and develop methods to target MRD. So one of our
targeting MRD trials is a combination of Revuminib plus Venetoclax. So it is very similar to the
Intercept, except that we're trying to one-up Andrew Wei by adding Venetoclax. So MRD in here
is FLO. The definition is 0.1%, the reason why, or the sensitivity is 0.1. We're trying to, we use FLO
because that's the easiest way to get it through the FDA. Molecular would have been better, but it's
not a validated assay across the US and it would have been harder to have an IDE for the NPM-1 MRD
assay. So the primary endpoint is clearance of FLO by MRD by FLO, so to 0.1. And throughout the cycle,
we are, throughout the treatment, we are collecting samples to understand MRD. Revuminib is at the
recommended phase two dose. We're past dose escalation now, and we're adding Venetoclax day
one to 14. But what I would also like to highlight as something particular about menin inhibition,
this was brought up in previous talks,
is that it may be modulating immune response. So it's not just direct targeting of leukemia.
So menin inhibition affects expression of MHC-1 genes. This is by interacting with
the polycomb complex. So in this paper, which was published in Nature Cell Biology in 2023,
a small cell lung cancer model had better killing when combining T cells plus menin inhibition. And
it showed that those T cells are activated and can kill, in this case,
lung cancer models. And it showed that those T cells are activated and can kill, in this case,
lung cancer. And this was taken further through a series of publications. So there's one
publication in Hematologica focused on bleximinib that shows that this is what we see in leukemia
as well, upregulation of MHC-1 and 2 genes and an anti-leukemic effect. So not just targeting MRD
with bleximinib that is susceptible to BLEXI, so MPM1 or KMT2A, but also inducing a specific
T cell killing in those. And there's a more
recent paper published in Blood that showed that this is a phenomena across men and inhibitors. And
there may be activation of these viral antigens that is inducing the T cell function and leading
to an anti-leukemic effect through a dual role. So targeting of MRD and activation of the immune
system. So this is the granularity of this data. You see upregulation of C1. You see that it
happens with the MI.
You see that it happens with S1. You see that it happens with S2. You see that it happens with
S3. You see that it happens with S4. You see that it happens with S5. You see that it happens with
S6. You see that it happens with S7. You see that it happens with S8. You see that it happens with
S9. You see that it happens with S10. You see that it happens with S11. You see that it happens with
S11. You see that it happens with S12. You see that it happens with S12. You see that it happens with
S13. You see that it happens with S14. You see that it happens with S13. You see that it happens with
S14. You see that it happens with S15. You see that it happens with S14. You see that it happens with
in the intercept study so in steady state menin does not affect count recovery uh genetic knockdown
of menin in this model and the steady state had stable counts white count neutrophil lymphocytes
but if you see to the right whenever there is stress hematopoiesis so genetic knockdown of
menin plus chemotherapy or radiation therapy there is an impact on hematopoietic stem cells and long
term count recovery so that would tell us that in the setting of combination or post-transplant
menin inhibitors could affect count recovery and this is what we saw with initial look on
review minute post-transplant so all the review minute trials that have happened including the
phase one and two uh included review and maintenance it was empowered to you know test
the addition of reviewing a post-transplant but it gave us some experience showing that those drug
can be given but the most common side effect is thrombocytopenia so similar to what was seen in
the intercept most often we just reduce uh the drug by one dose level and it is sufficient um
hannah goulard from uh from md anderson will be presenting at asco our experience with review
minute post-transplant so we've had you know multiple patients now and it's mostly uh
tolerable and hopefully improving relapse free survival based on historical control
uh but the main side effect is thrombocytopenia so for these reasons i think there are multiple
preclinical studies to support men and inhibition post-transplant maintenance so this would be a
dual role it would be targeting mrd post-transplant so hopefully delaying relapse until the gvl kicks
in but i also think that among drugs that are being tested men and inhibitors have a high
potential of inducing gvl so hopefully we get you know more money for what we're doing by by
inducing gvl it is critical to note that menin is important in stress hematopoiesis that's going to be
potentially a factor in post-transplant maintenance so if we're trying to establish
those doses post-transplant should be selected carefully so that there's no increased toxicity
and that's why there are now multiple trials launched to test men and inhibitors post-transplant
thank you